so it's the final day of NATO meetings
with defense ministers discussing how to
best deal with Moscow and increase arm
shipments to Ukraine Secretary General
Jens scholtenberg pledged the alliance's
full support for Ukraine saying it will
stand with the country as long as needed
we will stand by Ukraine for as long as
it takes we will step up our support and
in particular we will provide a more air
defense systems to Ukraine are also
welcome uh the very strong message from
the International Community yesterday
the vote in the U.N was a clear
condemnation of the illegal annexation
of Ukrainian territories and a clear
call on Russia President Putin to
reverse these decisions and to respect
the territorial Integrity of Ukraine and
Germany sent the first to four promised
air defense systems to Kiev on Wednesday
it says this is the most modern weapon
it has in its possession and will
improve Ukraine's rate of shooting down
Russian cruise missiles on the same day
French president Emmanuel macron
promised to send air defense systems and
Radars to help protect against drone
attacks
well to discuss this Hamid is in Kiev
and Natasha Butler is at that meeting in
Brussels Natasha let's start with you it
looks like Ukraine's demands of being
partially met at least more weapons are
on their way to Ukraine
that's writer Britain and France both
both promising more air missile defense
systems for Ukraine as other as well as
other weaponry and ammunition that adds
to those pledges already made by Germany
the Netherlands and the United States
we've also had here at NATO headquarters
a bit earlier NATO defense ministers for
14 member States including Germany and
Belgium signing a joint declaration to
agree to jointly buy more air missile
defense systems now at this stage we
don't know whether that would be to
replace some of their dwindling domestic
stocks as they send some of this
Weaponry to Ukraine or whether those
would be to send directly to Ukraine but
either way what it does show is a real
sense of commitment to try and support
Ukraine and also to answer Key's demands
because of course Vladimir zelensky the
Ukrainian president has been saying over
the past few days the what his country
really needs is an air Shield
particularly in light of those multiple
missiles bikes that we saw a little bit
earlier in the week well Hodder you're
in Kiev what are people there saying do
they feel that Western powers that NATO
are doing enough to help Ukraine
well people always say that they thank
all the countries that are supporting uh
Ukraine but you know you just mentioned
earlier this week when there was more
than 80 airstrikes launched against
Ukraine including here in Kiev and
people always wonder why the skies
haven't been closed that's a demand that
ukrainians have had ever since the very
first days of the war President Vladimir
zielinski having repeated that many a
time but certainly now getting air
defense system is the priority because
if there's one military uh up that the
the Russians have at the moment while
they are losing ground on the
battlefield why they're trying to
regroup and bring all these mobilized
soldiers to the front lines while the
one advantage they have is that they're
able to strike Ukrainian cities as far
as leviv which is by the polish borders
so certainly more air defense system is
something that would be very welcome and
especially in cities like mikolai
ozaporija that come I would say on a
daily basis on the missile or rocket
attacks now this with also the U.N
resolution that was passed yesterday in
New York calling 40 a territorial
Integrity or condemning the annexations
that took place a couple of weeks ago by
the announced by the Kremlin claiming
that now donates lugan's parts of Zappa
regia and parts of Herson region were
within the boundaries of the Russian
Federation that would be welcome too but
many people will also tell you here that
the UN has it has had many more
resolutions in the past about
territorial Integrity mainly in 2014
when it can them the annexation of
Crimea again in 2020 when it called for
all the Russian troops to pull out from
that Peninsula so U.N resolutions are
good they're symbolic president
zielinski talked about it saying that it
was a historic move but again there is
frustration there against the U.N the
Ukraine has been asking over and over
again to actually expel Russia from the
security Council something that is not
on the table at the moment but put those
two together more pledge of air missiles
our defense system missile and U.N
resolutions I think Ukraine does feel
the support of the International
Community
reporting from Kiev Natasha Butler and
Brussels thank you to you both